[Music]
meanwhile rock'n'roll royalty and their
offsprings are proving they're just like
us showing off their iconic family bond
for Harper's Bazaar behold the adorable
offspring of music's first family the
boss Bruce Springsteen graces the
Harper's Bazaar cover with his 26 year
old daughter Jessica who by the way was
[Applause]
and just like any normal father-daughter
dynamic yep he embarrasses her
she recalls this 2012 moment of being
brought on stage to dance in Paris
saying quote I'm still traumatized a
fresh-faced Christina Aguilera who
describes herself as a quote
mama bear closes with her young cubs and
10 year olds Max and three-year-old
summer and check out Mariah's seven year
old twin Moroccan flexing his muscles
ryan told the et he takes after his dad
Nick Cannon and is quite the little
comedian he's freaking hilarious I
spilled vitamin water and the bed and we
were watching a movie and he goes don't
blame me young lady I was like where did
this kid come from I'm fed of him no I'm
more proud of her 41 year old Liv tie
their embraces her rock and dad and
Aerosmith frontman her breakout role of
course was in his 1993 music video for
crazy
and check out Nicole Richie lounging on
the lap of her soulful dad Lionel
she told the magazine they are very much
like saying they will quote do anything
for a laugh in a nutshell we're
desperate show ponies and those icons
are gonna be celebrated again at the
magazine's fifth annual icons event and
Christina is also scheduled to perform
[Applause]
[Music]